this video is sponsored by ridgewallet
alright so i
sort of screwed up for those of you out
there that saw last week's video and
took a cursory glance at the comment
section
you may have noticed
yeah not great and to be honest i
totally see where a lot of you guys are
coming from
others not so much like i mean some of
you got really angry one person even
said that i was scummy and cowardly for
featuring my new puppy in what he called
a
lower quality video now most of the
comments were of course great critical
and very fair
but to those few mean people quit
harshin my chill
bro with that said admittedly last week
was for me abnormally chaotic and so
this week on top of giving you my first
impressions of the crazy reverie arc
i want to before i get into that take
all the criticisms you provided me in
the last video and give you all what
should have been already part of last
week's video
so think of this as part three to whole
cake island
also discussing reverie in depth if only
there was another way we can mix that
cake
[Music]
big mom's flashback personally i thought
this was my biggest misstep in last
week's video and to be honest i'm
delighted i took another closer look at
it this week
while i neglected to mention a host of
other aspects with the rest of the story
with this one
i think i misrepresented it greatly last
week coupled with my normal workload i
had to look after a new puppy and sort
out moving into my new place
now these aren't excuses but they are
simply to provide you with context as to
why the video was the way it was last
week thankfully however reverie while
being massively entertaining and
interesting thanks to its relatively
short length it allowed me time to
reread this part of the story as well as
other sections of last week's material
and today i want to discuss what my
impressions were
and they are quite different funnily
enough i understand that this story
isn't designed to foster sympathy but
something i want to make clear is that i
don't think
that that is the sole purpose of a
flashback either i've never thought that
in the case of big mom her flashback
provided greater unseen context for the
character she became and the
circumstances she fell
into this doesn't necessarily garner
sympathy but it does garner empathy it's
easy to see how and why she became the
way that she currently is
empathy instead of sympathy and that's
an important distinction something that
heavily colors the pages of this arc is
the theme of family and what that means
for each driving force in this story
with big mom's pirates it's sort of
forced diversity ensuring and allowing
everyone to be part of the group but
only those she accepts is interested in
or finds value with
germa in sanji's family is based on
order with it basically boiling down to
family members that are literally
engineered to be placed in a
hierarchical structure
with their sole purpose being to serve
the father figure and lastly the straw
hat crew with possibly the healthiest
approach to helping out and supporting
each other in reaching this common goal
already this is far more interesting and
complex than i initially drew attention
to so let's look at big mom's dynamic a
little closer
as i alluded to earlier the point of the
flashback wasn't necessarily
sympathy but to instead demonstrate how
and why she became the way that she is
having been born with an unnatural level
of strength reprimanding her became
night impossible this led to her
becoming isolated and lonely thus
creating a longing in her for a family
unit
however when she does eventually find
people that take her in no one is able
to teach her how to behave due to her
tantrums and enormous power that's when
the character of mother carmel comes in
initially looking as though she takes
the reins of the young big mom she
instead enables her reinforcing this
notion that everything she does is okay
and that her heart is in the right place
despite the destruction she may have
wrought on a town or the hurt she may
cause unwittingly or in some cases
wittingly this proved to be incredibly
dangerous for big mom as it reinforced
the notion that her motives
are just and that she can do no wrong
despite her in essence being a selfish
child that has now grown up physically
but not
mentally still retaining the same awful
toxic mentality she had when she was a
child with still
no one able to take her to task for it
and this manifests ironically or perhaps
appropriately depending on your point of
view in her own children feeling more
distant from her
throughout the duration of the story we
are greeted by the harsh and unkind
behaviors from her children as they
attack
all those who oppose them like to avoid
confrontation with their own mother
and as is made evident with a certain
character i will get into in just a
moment demonstrates a need for a strong
reliable father figure within the family
itself
in essence the flashback with big mom in
addition to illuminating for us the
desire for her to have a family
it also highlights the origins of her
defective approach to parenthood and her
skewed views on the world
resulting in children that are terrified
to tell her the truth many that want to
distance themselves from her and many
that have behavioral issues that have
stemmed from her unkind and warped
vision of how she ought to carry out her
duties
as a mother the soolong forum i thought
this was cool
but something i think is important for
me to reiterate at this point is that
my jam is clever writing and it sort of
ends there
if oda surprises me or does something
interesting with the plot then
that's what i adore stuff like robin not
wanted to go underneath the
revolutionary deck at the time skip
sabo being foreshadowed with the sake
cups way before he made this return the
consistency in luffy's dialogue
those are my super saiyan moments now
that's not to say that i don't
appreciate aesthetically cool moments
like gear 2 or this
i do very much like that time luffy did
the champion walk on fishman island
where he used his hockey to put
everyone to sleep that was amazing
amazing for me however because
i knew beforehand that luffy has been
trained to hone this ability prior
and now it was manifesting in action it
was a payoff
however that doesn't mean that i like
all these techniques just because they
are cool techniques
for instance way back on drum island
chopper introduced us to the rumble ball
mechanic
out of nowhere at the end of the arc
there was never a precedent established
for such a devil fruit to be enhanced by
various substances and thus i treated it
like exposition
rather than a reveal or a surprise to
enjoy but that doesn't mean i didn't see
the utility or visual flair from the
move
it just meant i didn't appreciate it as
a reveal or a surprise which is what i
love about one piece personally
when it comes to the zulung form
introduced to us by carrick i thought it
looked really awesome and i thought it
offered much like choppers monster
ability
a nice ace in the hole once the right
conditions were met for carrot i like
how it also encouraged the crew to get
involved in order to protect her while
she's in that state the same is true for
when pekoms takes off his glasses and
transforms himself into his too long
form to help them escape
i wasn't super attached to pekos
personally but strangely i'll admit i
probably have more reason to be close to
him than i did pedro however maybe
because his character was more
interesting or perhaps he had more
exposition via flashback pedro sacrifice
hit me much more intensely than petcoms
did regardless there are plenty of
things mechanically and visually to love
about the soolong form and i'm
interested to see
what it offers up in the future for her
and the rest of the crew
in essence it was a nice piece of
exposition katakuri vs luffy
i think the worst part about this
section within my last video is that
while i sort of got what oda was going
for
i didn't fully expand upon it or
appreciate it and instead focus on the
set pieces of the battle as well as the
beats that affected me the most
while i was reading so let's take a
deeper look and talk about katakuri
versus luffy
and what i thought about big mom and his
relationship with her and don't worry
i'll also mention snake man
as i mentioned in my last video katakuri
isn't an evil character and for the most
part is vastly more emotionally mature
than most of if not all of his siblings
so much so he effectively acts as the
father figure for his family while big
mom is obnoxious loud and bombastic
practically every single scene katakuri
takes a partial or leading role in
he is always relaxed and is willing to
either take the appropriate action or
throw himself into harm's way
for the betterment or protection of his
family big mom's fear of future
portrayals and lack of trust is exactly
what causes her to lash out often times
and yet it's this ability to remain
relaxed is what fuels katakuri's ability
to see short steps into the future it's
quite literally his greatest strength
despite knowing when something bad is
about to happen either at the wedding or
during the early stages of the fight he
demonstrates an ability that big mom
never has been able to show the ability
to take bad news in his stride and to
plan accordingly this is why we see
numerous instances where he is spoken of
in exceptionally high regard amongst his
siblings he is the best parental figure
they have he is who they go to if they
have an issue
he is the one that keeps the level head
when big mom is lashing out
and he is the one that takes on the
biggest threat to his family
when straw hat luffy comes to town i
think perhaps however the most tragic
part of katakuri in this fight with
luffy is how his fickle relationship
with his family is laid bare
despite being the father figure or older
brother to the rest of his family he's
acutely aware that if he relaxes and
projects who he really is unto them i.e
letting down his perfect tough guy
persona
they will reject him and it's this
specific aspect of his character that i
think makes him a perfect foil for luffy
to help make an example of
both armed with very similar powers of
stretch they too have one
fundamental difference rubber by its
very nature can absorb damage and return
to normal shape automatically
but mochi leaves an imprint showing that
he has taken damage and therefore
isn't perfect throughout luffy's journey
he has failed dozens of times but every
single time he could rely on the support
and love of his family unit the straw
had crew to lift him up and to help him
where he needs it if at any point
katakuri shows weakness or a sign that
he isn't all that
then he has every reason to believe that
his family unit won't care for or
respect him afterwards
simply because they have all been raised
to value and respect the wrong
things in people this is exactly
something that luffy recognizes during
the battle and in an act of kindness
puts those ridiculing him to sleep using
his haki this also demonstrates a dual
function
obviously that luffy empathizes with
katakuri in this instance
but also that those who would ridicule
him are weak-minded
and therefore subject to falling asleep
from his haki power
and throughout this fight we see
katakuri come to accept who he is
and fight the way he wants to fight
overall
i find katakuri an interesting character
and a great vehicle in helping
communicate some of the more complicated
dynamics
under the explored themes within this
arc and to be honest the choice to
explore the theme of family within the
context of a pirate story concerning its
crews
is not only interesting but as i
discovered is also extremely versatile
and appropriate for the topic
enabling its author to examine and
explore dozens of different interesting
family dynamics and not to mention
traumas using the various crews as
proxies for real families
i mean it's hardly even a proxy really
the straw hat crew is as much as family
as my onus
[Music]
something i was sort of surprised a lot
of people desperately wanted my take on
was the snake men
from luffy's showdown with katakuri at
the end of the fight and while i
understand that it's sort of
a culmination of gears mixing with his
exploration into color of observation
hockey narratively it didn't set my
world on fire and visually it did
nothing for me personally
now that's not to say i didn't like it
at all i did like it i liked how it
played into the dynamic of the fight and
all of that but outside of it i thought
it was
pretty lackluster that is until i saw
the anime's version
oh my god after watching the
corresponding episodes and animation
these fights really are
on another level and it's one of the
first times i've seen an anime snippet
that i vastly prefer
over the manga this isn't a situation
where of course action is going to be
better in animation than isn't manga
that's not the case at all i much prefer
dragon balls action in the manga that i
do in the anime but with this specific
scene in one piece it
is out of this freaking world personally
when i received all those messages about
my not mentioning snake man i was like
okay i kind of get it but it wasn't that
good then i saw this and it all made
sense
i mean i'm sure there are plenty out
there that love the manga's version it
just didn't really set my world on fire
as well it's much more impressive in the
anime i think
narratively speaking there was a ton
going on in this arc and i really
enjoyed it within this
arc oda has demonstrated a level of
writing that i think is significant and
perhaps setting a new standard for
himself within the series
naturally you'd expect to see a certain
level of depth with the primary
characters like sanji big mom or luffy
but within this story despite
contributing comparatively less than
those three
others have still been explored and
fully realized far beyond what was even
necessary to sell the plot of the main
story in the first place
characters like katakuri obviously but
even jinbe whom on top of being
established of having promised luffy to
join his crew way back in the story is
given ample opportunity to develop and
to express himself as we learn about his
allegiance to big mom
and his journey in finding freedom
within this story coming to a beautiful
climax where he must yet again
postpone what he has gone through helen
back to get his place within the crew of
the straw hat pirates in order to buy
them enough time to escape it's really a
wonderful little self-contained story
with a great payoff and it's really
something i thoroughly enjoyed
so with all of that finally out of the
way i think it's time for me to discuss
the main topic of today's video over the
last week i've been reading this arc
quite a bit and today i want to give you
all my first impressions of thoughts on
and review for
the turbulent the wild and the crazy
reverie arc
[Music]
this video is brought to you by
ridge.com tnm
most people are still using wallets
designed in the 1990s and
in this modern landscape it's seriously
outdated and i should know
i've been using the same wallet since i
was 15 years old and that means i've
been using some outdated wallet for the
last 14 years of my life
in the same way phones have gotten more
practical and compact over the last few
decades so too of wallets
and it's honestly made a massive
difference to my pockets personally i
hate having cumbersome items in there
and this totally fits my new lifestyle
it holds up to 12 separate cards plus
room for cash and there's over 30
different colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium to
choose from
and if that wasn't enough to win you
over yet check out their thirty
thousand five star reviews the durable
nature of each of these wallets comes
with a lifetime warranty so
in theory you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life and the rich team
have told me that they're so confident
that you like it that they'll actually
let you test drive it for 45 days
that means you can send it back for a
full refund if it's not up to your own
standards
right now there's a special offer going
where you can get 10 off
with free worldwide shipping and returns
and you can get all of this by going to
ridge.com tnm and using the coupon code
tnm link is in the description
you're nothing but a joke but you get
the punchline
and you
[Music]
revery upon my first read-through struck
me as rather strange and
mysterious so let's get into it and see
what i thought of each individual
section
chapter by chapter chapter 903 903
despite being the first of the reverie
arc is a reflection on the prior whole
keg material instead
i thought it was rather neat that sanji
was given a higher bounty than zoro now
something that he can talk about with
him later i mean it totally makes sense
given what he's done
plus his association with garma 66
additionally i thought it was a great
narrative decision to give sanji a
symbol of his family to follow him
around this suit his family made for him
while he doesn't want to wear it you
absolutely know he will in the future if
his relationship with his family
improves on or if
the circumstances require him to give up
his pride regardless he'd be wearing
that suit at some point in the future
something i also liked was the inclusion
of kobe every few hundred chapters we
check back
on him and every time we see him he
again has grown exponentially and
right now has developed his hockey to an
impressive level not to even make
mention of his physical ability
demonstrating also that he has yet to
gain devil fruit ability by swimming and
easily protecting a royal ship on the
way to the reverie from attack
[Applause]
and finally in this chapter the gag or
reveal surrounding luffy's bounty number
is a bit of a cheat in my opinion
initially towards the front of this
chapter it's announced that his bounty
has fallen to 150 million berries with a
small panel demonstrating that reality
as luffy holds up the poster
now as the chapter progresses and we see
the headlines color luffy's exploits in
a positive light
because of this i began entertaining the
idea that this lower bounty number could
very well be a reward from the navy or
might have been a strategy on behalf of
the navy but it turns out it was neither
of those things and luffy just can't
understand big numbers because
his real bounty number is 1.5 billion
now i think this
is sort of a cheat because the initial
picture we see luffy holding up at the
beginning of the chapter
doesn't have a comma behind the one
chapter 904 not much really happens in
this chapter
it's mainly for exposition and with it
just being 15 pages long it's one of the
shortest chapters i've yet come across
in this series
essentially we're made aware that the
revolutionaries are planning a war
against the celestial dragons
good idea i guess we get introduced to
the military captains of the
revolutionary army in karasu
lindbergh bello betty and morley we also
get to see them help a village rise up
against pirate oppression while
demonstrating for us their powers
among the four mentioned i thought that
abetti's devil fruit power has the most
potential for
creative narrative input other than that
in chapter 904 i don't really have
anything else to talk about
[Music]
chapter 905 in this chapter we get to
see the new marine ford headquarters
while also demonstrating that they are
using the old marine ford as a g1 base
we also find out that fujitora isn't
married this is funny because
marijua is an incredibly sacred place
and fujitora has already been banned
from returning to military grounds
without luffy reprimanded or captured to
be brought to justice it's a small panel
but it highlights his personality
brilliantly i think
using loose logic to grant himself
access to the most sacred area in all
the world
while there a rather interesting
conversation happens where he cites that
there's no longer any need for the seven
warners of the sea because
of something vegapunk has created and on
the other end of this conversation is a
brand new navy admiral in the shadows
called ryokugyo with that said the vast
majority of activity in this chapter is
spent introducing
and reintroducing characters as they
arrive to the reverie with an
honest abe type character called king
hamburger
and a mexican type
character called king taco and yes i
felt uncomfortable saying that but the
most notable arrivals have to be the
representatives from the ryoga kingdom
princess shirahoshi her brothers
and king neptune while being guided by
garp
which is really cool to see him again
but more so it's sort of lovely getting
to see
shira hoshi's reaction to the surface
world continuing the royal introductions
as they arrive at the reverie we also
get our first shot of steli
the smarmy reprehensible adopted sibling
of sabo we haven't seen this dude since
the post-war arc and now he's
all grown up sort of chapter 906
we finally get to see marijua surrounded
by its very own man-made forest
with stunning structures and slaves
underground to add to the world building
helping the facility to work again
however there are tons of
reintroductions to older characters in
this arc like waffle vivi rebecca dalton
dr kureja
among others while also dedicating
sections of this chapter to remind us of
who these characters are and what their
connection was to luffy in this story
which is
sort of humorous to me not because i
don't think these are justified
to be here but because i only read those
stories a couple months ago and they are
still very very fresh in my mind
[Applause]
whereas when these chapters were
released some of those stories were
told over 15 years prior but perhaps the
most interesting part of this chapter
and what would be i assume one of the
main talking points of this arc
is that weird big crown shadow man with
a massive straw hat in the cold
literally no idea what this means or
what is happening here exactly but it's
certainly interesting and i will
absolutely talk a bit more about what i
think about it later on because this
won't be the last time we see him
her or it in this arc alright so to be
honest up until this point the reverie
arc with all that it's been built up to
be
i wasn't super enthusiastic about what i
had seen thus far i mean
sure some of it was interesting but a
lot of it was sort of side dressing or
super ambiguous apart from that weird
shadow man meeting old characters again
seeing some heartwarming scenes were
pretty much the things that were taking
center stage with the most noteworthy
being luffy's reputation starting to get
to the level of an emperor of the sea
these are all cool for sure but at this
point in my read through with only two
chapters left in the ark
i was really hoping there was gonna be
more and thankfully
there was chapter 907 this chapter was
probably the most enjoyable chapter so
far
for me mostly because stuff happens here
that has massive repercussions the other
chapters were great and all but large
portions of them were spent introducing
or reintroducing characters
like the introduction to the
revolutionary captains that's great but
i can't do anything with that
information right now
it's exposition same goes for the
reintroductions of steli shirahoshi
rebecca vivi and all the others
and speaking of evie i think the most
important thing about the princess comes
later and i'm guessing
it might have something to do with the
fact her bloodline came from the 20
original founders but decided to live
amongst the people instead
gonna put a pin on that for just a
moment the chapter itself kicks off with
a bang with two emperors of the sea in
big mom and kaido attempting to form an
alliance to take out luffy
i like this personally because it helps
set up what i can assume will be the
main plot line of the wano arc
this is the first time someone in this
arc has set their eyes on luffy so i
guess that makes sense
also something that i thought was a
blink and you'll miss it moment was garp
mentioning the big cheese before roger
he refers to an error prior to roger
being that of
roxas whomever or whoever they are they
were involved in the event with garp
that led him to becoming a naval hero
and once that scene is done we see it
the big chair
steli was an interesting character
within this particular part of the story
and i feel like he'll be made an example
of later on perhaps after oneo another
expository dump like this one is
because right now he's a terrific
vehicle to help the audience understand
the significance of various things
he's tremendously eager to become a
celestial dragon and inquires about
the big chair essentially this chair is
never to be sat on it's there to act as
a symbol that no one person
may rule this world and thus helps
retain peace and balance between the
various kings and kingdoms that make up
the world
but steli he really wants to sit in that
chair alright now something that's set
up in a chapter earlier was that a
celestial dragon that we all know called
saint carlos has made it known that he
wishes to capture princess hirohoshi
because
he wants to but what's interesting about
this is that once he does
everyone is powerless to do anything
about it until
i really love this short but wonderful
scene this is the same celestial dragon
otahime shirahoshi's mother
saved way back in fishman island and
obviously much later in life her actions
have led the celestial dragon to
becoming a better person
and now he has saved her daughter's life
and get this
he is one of the don quijote family i
like this for obvious reasons that
include a long narrative thread being
paid off and linked with others but
i like what it means for the future also
from the very beginning these celestial
dragons have been depicted as the
garbage juice of people
and yet here we see some nuance of
complexity which i am
always going to be a fan of unless
you're talking about panel structure
and to end a tremendously informative
chapter we get a scene with red haired
shanks meeting with the five elders with
his only dialogue of note being
there's a pirate i need to talk to you
about i feel at this moment in time
luffy is too
obvious for him to be talking about but
he very well could be they surely
already know enough about
the young pirate and so i think he could
very well be there to discuss
either blackbeard or perhaps less
obviously trafalgar loft for reasons
concerning his op-op fruit and the
potential for creating an immortal life
but more on that a little later
in chapter 908 speaking of which chapter
908 this is the chapter where something
big goes down but funnily enough it's
not the reverie
in fact we don't even get to see the
referee we just see everyone file into a
room to begin the reverie and really all
that is nice with king neptune finally
coming around to realizing that there
are good and bad land dwellers much the
same as there are good and bad fish men
a lesson so many struggle with today
even within this chapter also is one of
the driving inspirations behind the
revolutionaries planned attacks
the freedom of their friend bartholomew
kuma who while no longer himself
is being beaten and abused by the
celestial dragons like few we've seen in
the series
it's a big sad for sure
and to be honest i could talk about cute
things like that all day but to hell
with all that because the implications
of this chapter's ending
is something groundbreaking and it
involves
the big chair all right so we understand
the hierarchy of the world government
right we have the kings of the various
countries and lands we have the
celestial dragons and we have the five
elders above that
during this arc thanks to our favorite
blind boy steli we understand that there
was a throne to never be sat on that
effectively worked as the throne for the
king of the world
this is when we hear chatter from the
five elders discussing how the nefertari
family dynasty are traitors to their way
after choosing to remain in the lower
realm this
is vivi's family however something more
pressing is worrying them with it only
being two years removed from the
paramount war and with the talks between
kaido and big mom
evident for all to hear they are worried
that they cannot maintain the world's
equilibrium forever and that the time
has come
for a great cleansing i have
no idea what that means really but i can
speculate however before i do
this tall shadowy boy is the great emu
emu or so he's called strewn across the
floor are tattered images of luffy
blackbeard and shirahoshi combination of
wanted posters and regular photographs
they are
all massively important individuals
within the world and
one that's missing i think to me is momo
with his power to communicate to the
massive elephant of zou
which makes sense as wano is perhaps an
unknown to the wider world however
what's interesting is that in his hand
is a photograph of princess vivi
as he scales the steps towards the
throne that no one is to be sat upon
the five elders then bow and ask if
another light is to be erased from
history
the only glimpse of his face or her face
we get
is through this panel and in it we see a
very strange
eye now my immediate reaction i will get
to but first i would like to bring to
your attention what my one piece secret
service has brought to my attention
first
firstly what's interesting and
immediately striking about this
individual is his eye
obviously so where have we seen an eye
like this before
well two places have been brought to my
attention mihawk
and the great elephant of zou somehow i
don't think either of them are beneath
that cloak but what it might be
indicative of is a deeper mastery of
hockey seeing as we already associate
that sort of design choice with the eyes
to be associated with hockey mastery in
the first place
with that said it's a tenuous guess
though i would be surprised if these
three entities weren't tied together in
some way shape or form what's more is
that the sword that was stuck
into the ground by the photos i am going
to hazard a guess as to the significance
of it it's been said through
conversations with steli that the
weapons dotted around the throne were
put there by the 20 that established the
world government
20 weapons now i've gone back over the
images of this throne but i can't get a
good
view of the weapons put into the floor
but no image shows all 20 weapons one
thing for certain though is that i
cannot see
all 20. in addition this emu guy is tied
with the responsibility of the void
century which
means that sword planted in the ground
which he was using could very well
be his own with the tattered ruin he's
left blackbeard and luffy's posters in
it's clear he's been aware of them for
quite some time and has been troubled by
their exploits made evident by their
tattered remains
shirahoshi however has more recently
come to his attention and has also been
recently stabbed since her utility has
just become known as i've said momo
still isn't widely known yet and
furthermore vivi's in the perfect
condition and in his possession
meaning her importance is clear but in a
way that is yet unknown to us
he could very well be a great ancestor
of hers i mean we do know the bloodline
she represents is important
and it was mentioned at the end of that
chapter yet again however that makes me
feel like it's a misdirection and she
might be required for a different reason
additionally something that was brought
to my attention is that the op-op fruit
may
have been used to prolong this emu
individual's life
it's been explained to us already that
the ultimate power of the apa fruit is
to grant someone eternal life in
exchange for the wielder's own life
so i wouldn't be surprised if this is
that man but
overall i don't think we have the means
with which to derive a conclusion just
yet
just a bunch of ill-refined theories but
it's interesting to say the least
or at least i don't i mean it could have
something to do with why the zoe
elephant is walking forever or where
it's walking too
it's a mystery and bizarre to say the
least and that's not even to make
mention of the poneglyphs and raftel on
a narrative first
impressions level i do have my own
thoughts on the utility of this reveal
and how it conflicts with my
expectations
from the outset these are not complaints
or disappointments just my internal
thoughts as i discovered this new entity
from about alabasta until now i sort of
assume the ultimate roadblock at the end
of this
journey for luffy would not be a person
but a concept an idea
a culture or sociological structure
usually in the real world
no one person is to blame for the
world's issues and that's what makes
solving global issues difficult
everyone has a different point of view
there's nuance and throughout this story
luffy whenever he's needed to solve a
problem is very
much a hammer in search of a nail and
he's tremendously effective as a hammer
don't get me wrong but it's the quiet
moments with luffy as he tries to
communicate with his crew
to work on a problem or with other
people where he tries to solve their
problems
using his emotional maturity is what i
always found to be the most interesting
aspect of his character and seeing as
luffy's solution is to typically
punch the bad guy in any given arc i was
sort of anticipating luffy's struggle in
grappling with and being confronted by a
more nuanced and complicated problem
than simply punching a person could
solve
seeing as up until this point there's
been no one person to blame for the
world's issues and even if there was you
would think they would be long since
deceased
however now there seems to be someone to
blame for everything and therefore a
problem that once again in theory
luffy can rectify with the right punch
maybe
i don't know it's a possibility now with
all of that said this is an amazing
story and i am in no way insinuating
that there will be no complexity
if anything this video has communicated
i believe it will be very complex
i was just sort of anticipating a
different sort of big bad if that is in
fact what he
is to take a different more nuanced form
to reflect the complexities odis painted
his world to have
rather than making it a much more
straightforward situation that being
to just take the guy out now in saying
that i appreciate how giving the
audience a goal is great
but again it seems sort of late to be
revealing this big bad
but who knows maybe he's been working
behind the scenes and we've known about
him since the very beginning that's
totally a very odor thing to do
maybe it was the mayor of windmill
village he's never supported luffy's
efforts
jokes aside though i believe there will
be plenty of complexity and nuance as
this story marches on in its final
stretch
with the navy showing some doubt in
various forces around the world
including the celestial dragons
demonstrating that they can be reasoned
with it's going
to be a very interesting and nuanced
story and that's for certain
[Music]
in conclusion when i started this series
i knew it was going to be tough i knew
that there was a reason not many
channels just pick up and review this
the way that i have and
last week i think i hit that wall for
the very first time which is why for one
i will be reviewing the axe individually
hopefully with these smaller chunks i'll
be able to dive into greater detail with
the wonderful story oda has written for
us
with that said that'll do it for today's
video i'll see you all next week when we
finally get to wano and thank you so
much for watching and thank you so much
for your patience
[Music]
you